hey everybody its Jesse and I hope
everyone had a good weekend
today I am streaming at home from my
basement so the quality might not be as
good as it has been so I'm hoping to get
480 480p quality and that's about as
good as I can get
I've tried to get better quality before
but it ends up just buffering a lot for
everyone so this is it for now
and not much I can do about it I already
have the best internet I can buy at this
location so unless I move from stuck
with it
the Internet at my office was down today
then they got it working but it was on
and off so I decided not to risk it and
I would just work from home seeing the
live chat Nathaniel says you can get
Google Fiber pay them a million dollars
for like a half a second I was like wait
I can get Google Fiber and then I saw
the next comments yeah yeah let me know
if you all can hear me I have a little
bit of a different setup usually I have
a like an external mic and I don't
that's at the office so I'm just using
the mic that's in my MacBook and my
laptop is actually on my lap so I don't
even know where the mic is in this thing
I just hope I'm not covering it up
accidentally but if you have trouble
hearing me let me know first I want to
go over what I've done since I did the
last stream so basically what I've done
this morning and I also go over a pull
request that I got and then we'll get
started okay cool so sounds like
everyone can hear me so good I was
always worried about theirs
since I'm in the basement my air
conditioner is down here so I hope you
can't hear it in the background it
doesn't sound too bad right now but let
me know alright so enough with the sound
let me let me show you let me show you
what's been done so I added sure the
package.json first make this a bit
bigger alright so we already had this
first three but I've added react router
and I'll show you how I set up the
router in a minute but then I also added
a pre-commit hook so I pulled this over
from our last project and I think I
think it was Vinay who had the pool
request in the last project that we did
that setup prettier and standard j/s and
it just enforced the style rules so I
wanted to set this up early on so that
if you all want to submit a pull request
you know all the code will all be in the
same same format all the time so that's
setup now and let's see what else
alright just a little bit to configure
standard Jas these are all the packages
so I added a mis dev dependencies so
babble yes lint husky lint staged
prettier and standard so if you're not
familiar with that basically all it does
is every time I go to commit so I do a
git commit it checks all of my
JavaScript and it formats it
automatically so I have it set to use
single quotes
no semicolons so and then all the the
normal standard J s rules so you can
check out standard J s and see what
those rules are if you're interested so
standard J s is the set of rules
prettier is the thing that actually
applies those rules to the code to
format the code and tell you truth I'm
not exactly sure what husky is I guess
Edvin a is the one that submitted this
pool request the last time so I know it
works but I'm not a hundred percent sure
how it works but I'm not worried about
that because I mean really like look at
these node modules I don't know how most
of these things work but they work and
that's how pretty much everybody's
projects are nowadays okay so that's it
for the package.json let me show you how
I set up the router so I imported
browser router route and linked from
reactor DOM and so for reactor outer
when you bring it in you have to bring
it down because there's also react
router you know for other things like
for native and different things so make
sure to remember the Dom I'm not even
sure if there is a reactor outer package
I never really checked so you pull that
in I wrap everything in this browser
router and then within it
I can make links like this so here's my
my side drawer menu now and instead of
normal like eight eggs I have these link
tags and instead of an href I say two
and then I just put the route and then
I've made some routes down here just to
kind of make sure it's working and give
me an idea and everyone an idea of these
are all the views that we need to make
so each one of these routes is is a
different view so the home view right
now every route right now just has an h1
but when you click on this route it'll
render
whatever you have inside the render
function for the route so eventually
it's gonna render one of these views so
I made pages for each view and it might
be hard to see there on the side but for
each view I've made a separate component
and I put it in a views folder so each
one of these routes will render that
view and then everything for each of you
will go into that component so it'll be
separated out pretty nicely we reuse for
every view this same title bar in the
same drawer side drawer with the length
here so this is outside of all the
routes and that's pretty cool so that
means the entire page pretty much never
has to rerender refresh because you know
this is this app bar is gonna stay the
same throughout all of it okay so that's
it for what I've done
let me show you what's with Sebastian
did with his pool request
okay I see in the live chat it says
Maxie May says you can auto format the
code on save with es lint and vs code
yeah I have I actually have something
that's Auto formatting things for me
like as I type but the thing with this
is it it enforces it across for everyone
so anyone who who clones this repo it
will enforce the same style rules for
them and they don't have to regardless
of how they have their editors set up so
yeah also I'm not using Visual Studio
code for this project so I'm using Adam
I have another project where I'm using
Visual Studio code but I'm sure that
there's a plugin for Adam as well but
anyway in this case I don't have to
worry about plugins or anything I could
load this in any editor and regardless
of how I loaded it it's still gonna
format properly like I could open it up
and Nana on a server and change
something and as long as I commit it
it's still gonna format properly I would
probably never edit any files on a
server in Anna but have my house unless
I was setting up the server initially
all right so let me pull over on my
other screen I'm trying to find the the
pull request
see I don't know why this is not right
at the top
oh my there we go are you sore senator
okay it's good pull request and I'll
bring this over now you all can see you
can check this out if you want to check
it out in more depth I'm just gonna go
over it really briefly just want to give
credit to Sebastian for doing this and
[Music]
that's kind of why is it anyway I wanted
it to get bigger but it just got taller
I wanted to take up the full screen so
anyway I want to give credit to
Sebastian for making this pull request
so you can see you know what he says
about it here so proper thing if you
remember last time we were talking about
the theme and how we we had kind of gone
through and figured out how to customize
the theme but I never hooked up I made
like a separate file for the theme but
then I ended up just testing it out
right in the end XJS file with an object
there instead of linking up the separate
file which would have been the better
way to do it so Sebastian went ahead and
linked everything up so you can kind of
see a lot of what's going on here so the
imports FUS theme that's the file you
know that we had made so he imports that
and then for this theme here he says get
my theme and then he brings in that I
feel same here so
really helpful be able to kind of you
know do all this so that we can start up
now and you know just get right to it
and not have to worry about setting this
this up and let's see all right so this
is the [ __ ] this is the theme file you
can see here and then in index he's
removed you know all the stuff that we
had in here and I think it was a Patrick
had the idea to leave the index file as
clean as possible and to to wrap inside
the app component to wrap everything
instead of wrapping it here like we had
done so it's clean and I took that same
idea and would in terms of the router
and I wraps browser router around the
app component in the app file not not in
in the index okay so thanks again
Sebastian I really appreciate that and
now let me show you there's really not
much that happened in terms of like
visually what you can see but I'll show
you anyway you can see I still have not
filled out my Trello board I want to
bring over the site and I'm just running
it on localhost so I can just pull it up
right here okay so here it is but not so
now we have our home view and you can
see here have these great default link
styles but I can click on it and you see
it change and the URL changed and now
we're at the poster for you so obviously
you notice
we need to do something to make this app
drawer automatically closed because
that's not really the expected behavior
when you when you click normally you
want it to close on click so I'm
actually somewhat surprised that that's
not the default so we're gonna I'm gonna
check out the documentation for material
UI and see how to do that and then we
can get into I guess probably start out
with the home view and start building
that out so let me check I'm just gonna
scroll through the live chat briefly
just to say hi see if there's any any
new people in here it looks like there's
some some people I haven't seen before
so hi and welcome
okay
all right so uh Patrick says didn't you
say you were working with your laptop on
your lap how do you have multiple
screens in the configuration so haha
yeah I just have I have my recliner
scoot it up as close as possible to a
table that's set up like pretty high so
that the recliner can actually go
underneath it so it's scooted up pretty
close and I have pretty decently long
cables so I have you know my laptop and
then two monitors connected to it right
now so it's it's an odd set up I you
when I was freelancing I used to work
like this all the time so it's a little
weird for me to get used to it from
being it like a normal desk and a normal
desk chair but I'm kind of getting used
to it it's not too bad no so anyway
that's how am i set up if you want to
see my setup I I put it on Instagram
earlier just to kind of show the the
weirdness of my setup so it's the last
thing I posted if anyways
anyone's interested and usually when I
work from home I don't work in the
basement but my kids are home and they
had friends over and so they were any up
there upstairs and I'm downstairs
otherwise it would be way too noisy to
do anything alright so first I do want
to I want to fix all right let's fix two
things let's make it close on click and
then let's style these links a bit
because we we obviously don't want to
keep the links like this so I'm actually
even wondering if there's some sort of
link component in material UI that I
just wasn't using so we'll see
so I'm going to check out I have a
material UI Doc's open
think already I think I'm open on my
other screen yep I did
all right well actually we did discuss
going back to material UI the alpha
version and I haven't done that yet and
I think some of you had said that you
can basically pull components from the
new version and use them with the old
version so that's probably what I'll end
up doing instead of you entirely going
over to the new version that should help
keep things I think a bit more stable
hopefully I'm I'm hoping that we can get
the best of both worlds and have the
stability of you know the older version
but then be able to grab some of the
components that we want from the new
version so hopefully it works out like
that if it doesn't then we might just
switch to the alpha version we'll see
when we get there which will be soon
because we'll need to use I do want to
use those columns that are in the newer
version all right so on my other screen
I'm just looking at the documentation
for material UI and I'm assuming that
there's just some option that needs to
be set to true or false to close it on
on click
hmm okay I think I know what's going on
let me see I don't know that's it I did
have that sake I thought for a second I
had this set incorrectly but I don't
actually I do want to see I had wondered
if it might be better to have the
sidebar open all the time but I'm not
sure that's not really what people are
used to right now from the old the older
version of this that we're making stuff
to think about it either way it still
needs to close on click because on a
smaller screen it obviously wouldn't
stay open so you still need to figure
that out
okay so stay open on request change okay
so what am I doing here on this honor
questions
you
I'm guessing that maybe this is yeah
maybe this is the problem let me check I
want to check the live chat quickly just
see if any of you have given some sort
of answer it's possible this you tell me
you may have already used material UI
and have gone through the same thing and
there the answer Oh
Rowan Rowan is a regular here in the
live chat and he's not feeling well
today so sorry about that I hope you
feel better and get some sleep cuz I
know what it's probably midnight in
India right now so yeah get some sleep
and get better
okay we have say hello from Vienna
Austria hey thanks for joining from
Austria actually the University of that
work at has a remote campus in Austria
and in gumming so I'm not exactly sure
how that afford glomming is from Vienna
I've never been to the other campus but
that would be cool
I can't I can't think of any reason why
they would need to send me to the campus
since I can work from anywhere but if I
can think of a reason I'm gonna try to
to get a trip to Austria for work all
right maud said hi from india and you're
a good teacher well thanks I appreciate
head
okay all right so all right Patrick says
haven't used the library but you can
define a click handler function at set
state to close and add that to the links
yeah that's what I was kind of thinking
is just have that click I would I was
just wondering there has to be some
built-in way of doing this because this
is not it's not like some weird thing
we're trying to do this is normal
behavior so and I kind of would like to
check it out let's see we talked example
undocked let me see the undocked example
so if you want to follow along its
material - UI calm and I'm checking out
the documentation on the drawer I'm not
putting it on my other screen because
since the the video quality is is lower
today there's probably not there's not
really much of a chance that it's gonna
be legible for most people so I'm just
gonna leave the code up on the screen
and then do like kind of the research
part on the other screen if it's
something really important that I think
you all would like to see I will pull it
over all right so right now I'm looking
at their example code just to see on tab
touch this handle okay
I think I found it No
okay I found it Patrick you were
actually on the right track completely
so basically your idea of adding a click
handler to the links it was exactly how
they handle that so it's it's nothing
that I put on the drawer but on these
menu items that's where I need to put
the click handler so I'm gonna go
through and just select all of these and
add this on touch tap this handle close
alright so now let's go check this out
all right
well that's how it was let me double
check that I did that correctly all
right it is supposed to be on the menu
item on touch tab was
I wonder okay I see I forgot some other
stuff as well
I need to actually add in handle clothes
because what's the point in calling a
function if you didn't define the
function in the first place alright so
this is what I was missing so obviously
if you didn't catch my mistake I was
calling this handle close but there was
no handle close function so here it is
now so now it should work all right
awesome well that one wasn't so awesome
because it didn't okay all right I don't
know if you noticed this so the behavior
that I'm getting now is that the it only
is a link if I actually click the link
it's only doing the routing if I click
over here it still shuts it but it
doesn't route so we need to fix that and
probably what we need to do is wrap this
entire menu item in a link
so let's try to rap that I was going to
try the first one just to see if it
works
oops keep going the wrong way uh oh I
see
didn't didn't get it all the first time
okay all right let's try this now so
we'll go we'll go to posters first and
then I'll come back and click on the
side there we go alright that works now
so we need to change all these which
it's kind of a pain but not really let's
see if I can change it all at once
alright that makes it a little bit
easier
yeah this is gonna be the tough part
because they're all different lengths oh
well
helped a little bit whoa does anybody
else ever play around with the multiple
cursor thing and sometimes you just have
weird things happen Li and occasionally
that happens to me where I I'm not
exactly sure if it'll work so I just try
it anyway and it ends up just pasting
stuff like every it's just totally like
it like just happened right it it didn't
work because these were different
lengths so I couldn't copy the way I
wanted to and then when I try to copy
one of them it copied all the links so
not really a big deal all in all of
multiple cursors just way more helpful
than then it is you know kind of a waste
of time at times when it doesn't work
all right so let me do these few things
I know this is a bit boring that it'll
be over in about 10 seconds or so now I
think I have a few vim users that that
watch as well so I'm sure there's
probably some super like magic them
stuff that could have done that a lot
faster because although I'd only use
them when I see people use it I'm always
amazed at what can be done but now these
should work so we'll give it a test just
to make sure we did it correctly posters
share story awesome okay so that works
great so leave that up so you can see
what I was doing in case it was too fast
and what were we trying to trying to
have things styled a bit better
yeah so basically I was surprised when I
saw the default link style here because
I had assumed obviously that links would
go here so that the default would have
been to override you know this link
style this normal like style but it
wasn't so I'm thinking maybe I needed to
add something into the mark-up that was
already built in to material UI I'm not
sure but we'll try it out if worse comes
to worse we could always just add our
own Styles that's not really a big deal
so I'm not really seeing anything that
stands out in the documentation I don't
want to spend a ton of time digging into
it the examples for the drawers aren't
showing anything so they just have the
regular menu items which is you know
where we got this these examples from
okay what potentially what could be
happening as well and I didn't
double-check this but it's possible on
the last project I did when I was using
the style JSX tag I noticed that at
times depending on you know how I
brought things in the Styles within that
tag never got applied so potentially
because this is a link tag and not an a
tag at some point along the line the
Styles try to get applied and can't find
the a tags that's basically what was
happening before so I don't know how the
styles are you know for these you know
like for instance for the menu item so
maybe actually I wonder if they have
looking to see if they had the menu item
component in here but I don't see it
let's see yeah they have some menus but
it's like drop-down menus
let's say they do use menu item
but again I'm not seeing anything
anything in here that's that has a link
on it
oh whoa at the very least uh let's just
get rid of these underlines so you don't
to look at them anymore actually let me
say there's some stuff here in the live
chat let me check it out
Szabo says hi from hungry how's it going
thanks for watching
hey Zanna how's it going glad you can
join us
XANA asked what's with the blur I'm
assuming you're talking about the video
quality yeah it's because I'm at home my
Internet's not as good as at work so
tomorrow I'll be back at work so it'll
be a good quality again tomorrow
okay
all right so Patrick has some advice
about our issue right now with the menu
items and styling so so as we could do
menu item primary text and then within
primary text put-put what we want the
text to be so let me let me try that out
then in that case actually if this works
I like this a lot better because then I
don't even need that closing tag and
that will just look cleaner in general
alright so we do that for logos let's
see how how it looks
mmm still giving us that styling let me
do a refresh just to be sure yeah it's
still giving us that styling Oh actually
just so I finally found where the menu
item properties are in the documentation
so they're on the same page as the
regular menus so on the on that sidebar
and material UI underneath the menu
selection if you scroll the bottom
they're there so let me check that out
all right I mean I could just put a
style tag in there it's not really let's
see yeah I don't think it has anything
yes a few people are asking about the
stream quality and live chat yeah sorry
I'm sorry my Internet's bad today
okay Sebastian says you can use a nav
link instead of link so you can add an
active class when you were on that
routing Sebastian does so is nav link I
can I use that with react router then
all right so let's
I want to see I actually want to see how
this gets rendered
okay I'm gonna pull this over on the
other screen here so y'all can see Oh
actually I almost forgot this I don't
want to actually I don't really want to
try it on my network right now I'm
afraid it'll make it even worse but so
some of you may remember at one point I
tried to use and rock I don't really
know you say it as ng or okay so that
you all could check out the site while
I'm while I'm developing and we used it
and it worked for like five seconds and
then everybody tried to access the site
and I hit the the limits for the free
plan well at some point another streamer
I forget exactly how it came up but I
told another streamer about what
happened with anger out on Twitter and I
guess the guy who maintains Engram you
know made it saw it on Twitter responded
asked what the problem was so I've been
emailing back and forth with him and now
I have basically it'll work I'll have
I'll have enough you know require I
don't know what level I'm at now but
basically it should work for the stream
it should be able to handle all the
requests and so I didn't have time to
set that up this morning so I'll try to
get everything set up tomorrow because I
would I I don't even have an grok
installed on this computer it's I have
it on my work computer but anyway I'll
get it working tomorrow and that should
be cool because then everybody can can
view I think Fabian was the one that had
that idea which it was a really good
idea and anyway so that'll be tomorrow
all right okay so Sebastian's saying if
I use nav link and so let me see let me
see again if I use nav link then I can
add an active class when you're on that
routing okay cool
that won't be hard to switch
okay I'm just gonna check this just to
make sure it still works yep still works
awesome
and then so I can do so Sebastian's
copying some stuff over into the into
the live chat for me to try out
actually which one did it go down was it
logos yeah okay so I should have the
class active on there now yep class
active okay so anyway this is at one
point I was trying to show you all how
this is getting rendered and I think I
got sidetracked so we have okay so this
is the div that all the links are in so
it all shows up
that's all
for some reason home has active and
logos have active not really sure why
that happened but anyway what I wanted
to see was these styles to say that like
yes this is the default and we don't
want that
okay let's alright so here's here's what
I haven't done yet in react and maybe
some of you have done this I can give me
some advice here because I know this is
possible so what I'd like to do is just
have some standard CSS for links so I'm
not always going to use the length tag
so I don't want it to be on a specific
component but just anytime that a link
is used so normally we'd put this in
this app CSS which should probably be
okay in this case because we could have
links anywhere but I know that you can
break up CSS and have it apply just a
different component so I suppose I don't
have to know it right now but it would
be cool to know the best way to do that
okay dead zombie says for first time
here hi Jesse I assume it says I love
your stream but it anyway thanks for
thanks for watching and again sorry
about the quality I probably won't do as
long of a stream just so that people who
are watching now and watch the recording
later don't have to suffer through too
long of this dream I like I'm seriously
thinking about moving just so that I can
get better internet B that's so if I
ever went back to freelance I might move
or like rent an office somewhere or
something cuz this is bad
okay so let's just put some styling for
an a tag here just to make sure I mean
it looks like there's there's nothing
that would be overriding anything so we
should be fine to put the a tag styling
here yeah this is all
basic
okay Patrick says remove dead CSS while
well on there good idea alright so what
am I not using pretty much none of this
right yeah whoops okay cool
if text-decoration
color was the color off can't even
remember yeah we want to for now I'll
just go black for now probably change it
at some point
okay cool we might have to do all right
awesome
I do want to see
okay cool
all right so at least we get rid of the
annoying underlines and all these work
and you can even click on the side it
still works so this is now operating
like you would normally expect this side
navigation drawer to operate cool all
right
I think this would be a good time to
commit these changes so I mean commit
that I have I'm gonna pull over my my
terminal because I imagine there some
people watching that aren't familiar
with the terminal so it's good I kind of
like to just show when I do this though
I'm gonna try to make it as big as
possible there we go okay so if you
aren't familiar with terminal yours
might not look like this there's some
custom things going on here with the
colors but basically the commands are
all the same so I'm gonna use get status
just to see what we've changed
we've changed app dot CSS and app dot j
s so now we're gonna do a git commit and
I'm gonna just do an AM and that means
we're going to add the files while we're
committing them and we're gonna add a
message as well right here in the
command so the message is going to be
probably just pretty much style drawer
links that's pretty much what we did I
mean I know we we fixed the click thing
to the W it they're hangin I can't type
today
I draw it links those terrible took me
like four tries to spell drawer alright
cool
so you notice we had it was taking a
little bit of time that was all that
stuff that we added with prettier you
know see husky was was running there so
it was checking our files and changing
so if we go back to our files there most
likely a bit different than how we left
them so I don't remember exactly how we
left them but if we would have been
really lazy with our formatting it
wouldn't have mattered because as soon
as we commit everything gets formatted
correctly according to whatever we said
is our style rules which we're just
using pretty much standard J s I not
even sure they altered it at all
okay did I push that and let me so I'm
gonna do a git push and this is gonna
make sure the code goes to our
repository on github and it's important
to remember to do a git push because if
somebody else is working on the project
they won't know about your changes
unless you push them or if you go to
work on it from a different computer you
won't be able to get those changes
unless you push them up which I
frequently work from two different
computers so I pretty much I normally
just push every time I commit it's not
it's not 100% necessary but that way I
usually don't forget and we're pushing
the master branch right to into the
master branch so that's why you have
master otherwise whatever our branch
name was that we wanted to push to we
would put it here instead of master and
now our changes are up on on github and
if you don't believe me you can check
the repo
the links in the description all right
so let's check here again and let's see
whatever the next thing is we're gonna
do I guess we can work on the home view
since this is functional and doesn't
look terrible and you remember our home
view is just gonna have six six cards uh
excuse me I was yawning six material
design cards and basically I wanna on a
large screen it'll be three and three
and then it'll scale down like two two
two and then all in a row on a very
small screen like on a phone and that's
it that's pretty much all we had on the
home screen before that's probably how
we're gonna keep it so we need to have
some callin classes and this is where I
wanted to try to pull in the component
from the newest version of material UI
which we're not using right now so let
me oops I had I hadn't I hadn't checked
the live chat in a while now I see
Sebastian was I was telling me to add in
exact did I not have exact anyone
see exact to the home routing
so you're saying I need to add to
Sebastian said I need to add exact to
the home routing so I'm assuming this is
talking about exact so why I'm not super
familiar with reactor outer I actually
just learned about it a few weeks ago
from the react course I was taking I'm
still taking it so I was using it on my
first project for that course so that's
why I decided to use it for this project
the two projects are actually pretty
similar in terms of the setup they're
both using create react app and react
router I set them both up with prettier
and standard Jas
okay so I guess that was the right spot
so Sebastian why would
what does exact do on when I add it
there to the to the nav link I'm
assuming now that that will solve the
problem we had of home getting the
active class as well I guess not
the BT refresh double check hmm Oh
actually should have it there because
we're on the home view let me take you
change that okay cool so that's what it
fixed then right okay so basically what
I'm saying basically what Sebastian's
saying in the live chats you all know
what's going on if you're watching this
later on if if you don't put exact here
then it'll try to match and put this
this active class on whatever matches so
since we had a slash in the URL
technically that matches this so by
adding exact we're saying what it has to
be just slash and nothing else so it it
would have matched anything any of these
links so that's why we did that and
actually I've done that down here on the
routes I just I didn't realize that you
could also do it on the links and
actually so
I'll probably need them to put that
active class thing on everything yeah
okay
Oh Timmy says hey have you shared the
Trello to do yet actually no I haven't
shared that or put the link anywhere
just because I haven't put in any to
dues so I've been slacking on that I had
thought about doing it this morning but
instead I just started working on it so
I'm gonna I'm gonna need to put them on
there soon otherwise I'll start
forgetting things and being a lot less
organized so usually at the beginning of
a project I frequently just start
working on it without doing all the to
Do's and then once I get into it a
little bit it's a lot easier for me to
see all the steps you know and think
about all the steps but right off the
bat it's I don't know why but I find it
hard to break down everything it's just
hard to think through all the steps when
you're not seeing anything at all on the
screen in terms of your project how it
looks or the code but probably this week
I'll need to lay out some steps here
okay let's see
should we I'm sorry
yawning again I didn't I didn't have any
caffeine today at all which is which is
rare I've been used to having either
espresso in the morning or G fuel in the
afternoon or sometimes both depending on
how much sleep I got oh um I should add
caffeine before this dream let me check
the time here okay let me I want to go
to the live chat I totally forgot to do
my my normal Pomodoro stuff so I never
really went back to the chat to check
for questions and it's been an hour over
an hour and I tried to check every 25
minutes so I'm gonna go back to the chat
I thinking that I'm a I'm a wrap up the
video because
basically we're at a point where we've
accomplished like a chunk of work and
that chunk was you know basically get
the navigation drawer to a point where
we want the only other thing I can think
of doing right now is maybe adding that
active style but I'm not 100% sure how I
even want that to look right now so I
think maybe this will be the end of the
coding portion and then I'll do all the
questions and everything I'd like to
wrap things up by maybe 3:30 so I'm it
doesn't look like there's a lot of
questions so I think that's definitely
doable but I have to take my son to his
karate class in about an hour or so so
I'd like to be able to eat dinner before
I do that and I haven't he hasn't been
to his class in like a month and some of
that was us being on vacation and doing
things on during his time but at least
once it was due to me getting home from
work a little bit late so I don't want
to make him miss the class again all
right so if you were just here for the
code portion of it thank you so much for
watching you can safely quit watching
now if you don't want to be around for
the QA if you have some questions or
you'd like to stick around to help
answer questions or you know hear the
answers then feel free to stick around
so if you have a question right now that
you'd like for me to answer or anybody
else in the chat to answer put it in the
live chat or if you can't stick around
you can still put your question in the
comments to this video or you can
message me on Twitter or any other
social media stuff that that I'm on and
I'll get back to you as soon as I can
and let me let me see what's in live
chat I think I covered all my normal
stuff that I say in
the stream so I'm gonna scroll all the
way back to the top make sure I didn't
miss anything I'm actually really
surprised at how many viewers we still
have because I know the quality is bad
I'm really sorry about that so I'm I'm
impressed that he all were able to stick
with it
oh Nathaniel asked way at the beginning
about streaming on weekends so yeah i've
never streamed on a weekend i'm not
entirely opposed to streaming on the
weekends because i do work on well
occasionally i do work on things for my
main job on the weekend if I have to
hopefully I won't have to do that again
for a long time because I've done quite
a bit of it recently but I work on on
other projects on the weekend so I have
my class my Udacity react course that
I'm doing projects for which it would be
cool to stream that although I wonder if
I'm allowed to stream it since it's a
paid course if they want like their
project on they're not I guess it
wouldn't be a big deal because the paid
stuff is really paying for somebody to
grade the project and give me feedback
so I don't think it would be a big deal
but I'd have to double-check also I have
some other just fun side projects and
maybe I will stream on the weekend
my oldest son really wants me to make a
video game and he's already drawn
everything that he wants me to do and
like crayon on big pieces of paper he's
drawing out the maps for like levels and
all the bad guys and the good guys and
all the weapons so maybe I'll do that I
think it'd be cool to try to make a game
in react I think it would help me build
up my react skills and be fun and then
maybe my son would get interested more
interested in what I do and that would
be cool too he's only eight years old he
just turned 8 over the weekend so I
don't really expect him to be that into
coding
okay
okay as I'm scrolling through I am I'm
seeing like some more new people that
are joining so welcome I appreciate you
watching and join it in the chat I
didn't notice this before Nathaniel said
earlier I wish Trello lets you resize
the columns it triggers my OCD I'm
working on my own list app to get around
that taking a bit of time to code though
oh that's really cool if you get your
app to the point where you'd like to
share it I think that would be cool to
see it send me send me a link to the
code or to a demo or something if you
get a chance okay so droid
drug pc geek says i'm a web dev but I
mostly work with JavaScript and a little
bit of nodejs because I programmed
discord box for fun that's really cool
cool thanks thanks for sharing thanks
for joining in I'd like to get into to
learn how to program BOTS preferably in
JavaScript since that's what I'm most
familiar with
I say yes as how are you integrating
material design with react and then maxi
my answers with material UI yeah it's
it's a let's hear you I this show says
nothing so much great about material UI
[Music]
yeah I have no particular I have nothing
really say about Mysterio UI yet because
I don't feel that I've used it long
enough to have an a really informed
opinion about it so after this project
I'm sure I'll I'll know what I think
about it Saba asks do you include the
CSS into jail
file or call it with a separate
reference let me bring up where I have
that so the the CSS currently is
actually I have two CS so I have an
index CSS file that gets included in the
index and that's just this there's some
basic stuff here and then we have an app
CSS file and that gets included up here
in the app file so that's where we put
the link really I I don't really know
why there needs really to be two
different files to be honest with you
this is just how it came like
automatically from create react app
because I'm not it's not like there's a
separate component other than apps so
like everything's flowing through app
into index so it probably could
everything could probably be in this
index CSS if we really wanted it to
apply everywhere maybe there is some
like performance reason why you would
want to split them up and not have a lot
in here I don't really know but
basically that's the way we're importing
them at you know at the top of our react
components and we could split it up as
much as we want so each component could
have its own separate CSS file which may
end up happening some components
probably won't need their own CSS if
they're not really doing a lot UI wise
so we'll see but we may may end up
having having it like that
Nathaniel says if I stay up till 3:00
a.m. then wake up at 8 a.m. I generally
feel sick that day and can't code
properly yeah so I've done that before
actually my my kids wake up at night
frequently and the baby wakes up really
early in the morning so if I stay up
late the odds of me having to wake up at
like 5:00 or 6:00 in the morning with
the baby are pretty high it seems like
it always happens like that if I go to
sleep early the baby sleeps in two and
then I get a lot of sleep which is great
but if I stay up late for some reason I
think the baby senses that and then
wakes up at five o'clock in the morning
and wants me my solution to that is
espresso and G fuel those are the days
when I have both and then I can't fall
asleep that night even though I'm
exhausted
so does anybody else have trouble
falling asleep even though you're tired
at night that's been happening me a lot
lately I know I'm tired I know I should
sleep but I just can't sleep I just I
don't know last night was okay I was so
exhausted I was able to fall asleep but
it had been after days of not getting
enough sleep
all right so I'm just going through the
live chat a bit more I'm about halfway
through now Nathaniel asks what packages
do you use on Adam I have a lot of
packages I'll bring up my my settings
right now and just let you see the
packages I'm not gonna go through all of
them I did that once on a video I can't
remember what video it was though that's
one of the video ideas that I have like
you know to do some pre-recorded short
videos on my own channel I have a list
of ideas a lot of them would come from
you all but one of them on the list is
go through all my packages and how I set
up my my editor how I set up Adam and
then maybe even how I set up visual
studio code as well I don't have nearly
as it much set up for visual studio code
but I do have some so anyway this is
I'll make this a bit bigger
I can't let's try to can command plus
and make it bigger and it did not work
so I'll just scroll through this as I'm
talking and that way you can see a
little bit of what I'm using some of
these I don't ever really use
I know I've downloaded things before
that I thought it sounded cool and then
didn't use them that much
yosef says using dual-screen is good for
eye protection but they shouldn't be in
the same dimension at least one should
be closer than the other that's
interesting I've never heard that that's
cool of to keep that in mind now that I
think about it I guess I do have them at
different dimensions most of the time
because of the way my desk is set up so
I wasn't doing that on purpose cuz I had
no idea there was any advantage to doing
that but I'll have to remember that now
I used to have a four monitor set up and
every monitor was at a different height
and everyone was at a distant different
distance from me and it wasn't on
purpose it was just I didn't have proper
mounts for the monitors they were all
different sizes because I just like
grabbed monitors when I could get him
like for free if somebody was getting a
new one they just let me have their old
one and then I just had him standing on
whatever I could find around the house
to put him on so it was an odd looking
setup but it worked
Marvin said disable caching and chrome
dev tools just to be sure I usually have
caching disabled every time dev tools is
open just by default fine if you're a
web developer which you probably I'm
assuming those people watching this are
I recommend doing that because I mean if
you're spending most of your time on the
Internet
developing you're gonna have dev tools
open and you're probably not gonna want
the cache to work because you want to
change something and see what happens
immediately so I just leave it leave the
cache off when dev tools is open all the
time because I've never had a case where
I wanted to cash a site that I was
working on
I see Nathaniel says just get a digital
ocean VPS and save to it in real time so
this is what we're talking about using
end rocks this is pay them like 40
dollars a month for high end dps and you
never ever fro them again yeah I think
I'll just go with end rocks since it's
been generously given for free so not
not really excited to pay $40 a month if
I don't have to owe anything you said I
get 32 CPUs for 640 a month that's more
than I pay for my house payment
mobbin says you can compress the stream
with Pied Piper I've never heard about
that I'll have to look that up
okay Patrick says that he's gotten SAS
working in his latest react project
that's awesome
I actually I'd really like to know how
how you get it working cuz I would love
to use SAS as well for my project so if
you get a chance you know send me a
message or something or let me know
comment depending on how difficult it
was probably just comment on the video
and that would that would be really
awesome
[Music]
okay see oh there says says that he was
yawning right before I didn't open and
send it to you then again with the delay
yeah there's a delay on the stream so
maybe we youand at the exact same time
he didn't even realize it
Daniel said how did he do that super
copy and paste so I'm yeah I'm guessing
that you meant like my um
my multiple cursors so let me
demonstrate that because that is a
really cool thing to do so if you're
using Adam or pretty much every code
editor it has this I don't know if the
hotkeys are always the same to do it but
basically I can highlight so I'm gonna
highlight nav link here and then I'm
gonna press on my my Mac using Adam I'm
going to press command and then B and
I'm gonna hold in command and every time
I press D while still holding in command
it highlights that same word at that
same string that you have highlighted in
the next spot that it appears in and
then you can edit it so right now I'm
just moving the arrow keys back and
forth and you'll edit everything and if
I were to paste whatever I last copied
it would paste in every position if I
were to highlight it and cut it it would
cut that out
so it's really really handy it's it's
kind of like if you don't have enough
things that you really need to use Find
and Replace like it would be a pain to
try to you a finder in place then these
multiple cursors make a lot of sense
once you have a lot of items then
finding your place is probably the way
to go and it's it's more powerful but
especially like if all the items you
need pretty much fit like within the
screen so you can see what's going on
then that's that's when it's most useful
so anyway I'm really glad you asked that
question actually because if there was
anyone out there anyone else out there
that didn't know about it really helpful
I actually I heard about it first I saw
it first on will Stearns YouTube channel
it's learned code Academy and there's
one of his videos I think he was
actually using sublime text when he did
it but I remember seeing him do that and
thinking like what what is this awesome
thing and yeah ever since then I use it
a lot when it's one of my favorite
things
Sebastian asks quick quick update of
what you've done so far I saw you merged
my my pool requests yes so I did I merge
your pool requests and those awesome
thank you thank you for that basically
the only other things that I've done is
I added in react router I added all
these you know these links and the
routes down here that you see and I
didn't do all this during the the stream
I did it beforehand and then I I added
prettier to auto format so with you know
standard J s so just like we had set up
on the last project that's pretty much
it
Hamzah ass react native when is it
coming is it coming
yeah react native is coming I can't say
window for sure so I'm doing a course
right now in the last part of the course
it is about react native so within a few
months I will have built something with
react native and at that point I would
really like to try to build something
for work for my main job with react
native this project I'm working on right
now might not be a bad candidate for
that so I may maybe I'll come back to
this project I just don't really think
I'll be able to learn enough about react
native to do this project with it but
this might be a good candidate to come
back to and and try it because it's
pretty simple it probably easy to you
know convert it I just I haven't used
react native yet so I just don't really
know how much for they thought it would
be
sorry for the noise I think my kids are
throwing things down the laundry chute
the laundry chute comes out right behind
me
saude asks about being a complete web
developer as a beginner yeah I would you
know start out with HTML and CSS then
JavaScript and you know free code camps
course is really good you could try free
code Academy no that's not what it is
this is code Academy learn code Academy
is a video series alright but I would
say start out with um with free code
camp and that's I mean that's a really
good place to start out
dead zombie s as a beginner front end of
what should I learn first I already have
a great knowledge of HTML and CSS I'm
learning Jay s at the moment so any
opinions I don't know I mean I would say
if you're already learning JavaScript it
kind of depends on exactly what kind of
stuff you want to work on but that's
much I'm sure you all can hear that my
three-year-old is just like making a lot
of noise right now itself all right so
I'm not sure why hey guys okay
I've won YouTube right now so I need you
all to be a little bit more quiet okay
thank you so anyway sorry about that so
anyway as a beginner like if you're
already good with HTML CSS you're into
jazz I I kind of think learning reactors
is a good way I mean I know I'm using
your act already so maybe I'm a little
bit biased towards it but for me I've
I've learned so much more about just
vanilla JavaScript by learning react
then then I ever had before also I will
say since I started doing the live
streams I've learned more than I ever
had before from you know everything that
you all share with me during this the
chat and from the pool requests and
stuff that I get so that that helps as
well but that's that's if you're looking
for you know somewhere to some goal you
know because there's a lot of stuff you
could learn I
I would go that way
Hamza says and Redux have you done a
video with Redux I haven't done a video
with Redux yet I don't really know a lot
about Redux so maybe it's coming
I think Redux I think I will also learn
Redux in the course that I'm taking I'm
not 100% sure but I think that was on
like the course outline so once I cover
that if I feel I need to work that into
a project then I will and we can cover
that as well
Suraj asks about UJS I have not tried
UJS yet I've just kind of heard a little
bit about it I haven't used it yet I
might use it at some point but I don't
really have a plan to use it right now
saad asked do you use PHP and HTML in
your project in this project yeah I mean
I use HTML I mean I pretty much use HTML
and every project in this particular
project I'm not using PHP in the last
project that that we did and that I
streamed I did use PHP I made a custom
WordPress plug-in for that project so so
occasionally I have used it on some of
my projects but I won't be on this
particular project I might use it again
on a future project though
Enochs courses and I'm late again good
day everyone
well glad you could join us for the end
here you can always catch the recording
Blake asks there Blake says I've been
using Adam text editor and it's been
really laggy I haven't messed with it
with it at all so there's nothing extra
any ideas to speed it up hmm iYou know
what I don't really know
I guess if if you haven't really added
anything to it and it's still like that
I don't know a ways to make it faster
there may be some ways out there
sebastian recommends visual studio code
and i would probably give you the same
thing i visual studio code seems to be
way faster than an atom from my
experience but i wasn't comparing fresh
installs in each one so i didn't know
exactly because my atom has so many
plugins and things so i'm not a hundred
percent sure you know just how old much
faster they are but i have noticed the
def into speed difference and Visual
Studio code is very similar to atom it's
free it's developed by Microsoft so I've
been I've been pretty impressed with it
so far you can actually set Visual
Studio code to use the same key binding
so that atom does so if you're used to
those you can switch over and just go in
the settings in vs code set it to your
atom key bindings and then you won't
even have to learn any new any new
shortcuts you know on your keyboard so
that was pretty convenient sanest says
all right so in regards to I think I got
to the point in the chat where I was
talking about not sleeping Zanna says
working in the garden really helps it
improve my sleep a lot yeah I've you
know what that makes a lot of sense
because I used to have a better routine
of like doing workouts and since I was
doing so much work you know so much
coding recently I just that that kind of
got pushed to the side so there's just
you know obviously there's not enough
time in the day so something had to be
cut out for me to be able to work that
much and that's what got cut out so
probably like you know I sit around all
day and I code and mentally I'm getting
fatigued but my body is getting nothing
so
yeah maybe I need to do some something
physical Daniel says get flux for your
computer the blue light from your
computer keeps you awake lower serotonin
levels yeah actually that's a good idea
I have flux installed on my PC but I
don't have anything like that on my Mac
so I guess I'll have to do that I do
that my phone set to switch when it gets
late but you know it actually and the
nights when it's been hardest to sleep
I've been up late building my my app for
the the course that I'm taking so that
makes a lot of sense
maxime a says meditate to sleep better
yeah actually that helps I mean I'm I'm
Catholic so sometimes I'll like pray the
rosary which is somewhat of a type of
meditation and that usually helps me go
to sleep
Sarah says yep I use melatonin yeah
actually I have tried melatonin before
I'll have to use that if I really can't
sleep I don't like to use it a lot cuz
it doesn't leave me really groggy but
it's definitely like I can tell the
difference to when I take melatonin when
I differ when I don't in terms of like
how rested I feel so it's not as bad as
like you know a sleeping pill but I
don't like to use it too much yeah
occasionally my kids give my kids
melatonin they actually really like it
they asked for melatonin all the time I
don't always give it to them but I think
they like they may be able to fall
asleep quickly Assad says Jessie
understand coding and when we make some
mistake in our code
I was stuck sometimes all the night I
was doing free code can't practice till
it really makes me strong in HTML CSS
and I moved into JavaScript cool yeah
it's good once you get into the jobs
part of free code camp it does get a lot
harder so there will be some times where
you know you got to spend a lot of time
on some of the algorithms and things but
you know keep working at it you know
you'll get there sometimes you got to
take a little break and then you know
when you come back to it the solution
seems like it's it's just a lot more
obvious
John says John Hanson says well those
Jas files and use become separate HTML
final public web page files
okay so what's gonna happen here is all
these files here and views will put in
these routes so instead of the h1 tag
we'll just have a tag you know based on
that component so did you say like
glossary right or in this case it'll be
hum so it'll be home Jas here so we'll
render home Jas and there'll be a
separate file so we'll go into the home
gas file and here's where we'll put all
our markup for that page and then it'll
render to the user it will seem like a
separate page it will have a different
URL but in reality it's not entirely a
separate page because we're not
rendering the whole screen so there's
still this whole menu system and nav at
the top that will stay the same and
never have to rerender so it's kind of
nicer like it definitely keeps the
appearance of separate pages but it's
not really a whole page which is why I
call them views set a page it's not like
I made up the term it's everybody uses
the term views I guess but I think it's
more accurate to say a view than a page
because it's not traditionally a page
like this normally as in sending it
requests to the server and getting an
entire page back so anyway let me know
John if that answered your question or
not
Zanna says love love and infusion if you
can accept the taste 1 TSP of dry love
and and a glass of water you put it in
the morning and leave it to evening you
drink it before going to sleep I've
never heard about that that's really
interesting
alright so sorry I can't pronounce
someone's asking question here in the
the characters are not the normal
alphabet that I'm used to so I can't
pronounce
sorry I guess it's Russian it says why
why does people prefer create react app
if you can't even configure webpack or
something similar for your own needs you
just have to follow react scripts
workflow yeah so create react app is
just really nice to get started if you
just want to start working on something
because you can get started in just a
you know a few minutes and have
something that works so you do sacrifice
customization for that so it's just a
trade-off that sometimes make sense and
sometimes doesn't for this particular
project we may not have to do any
customizations so it should work but for
some projects you would need to so it
just depends on what you're doing so if
you don't need to customize this saves
you a lot of time you can also inject
this and then do all the customizations
that you want so it's good to start it's
nice you can start a project like this
and if the project ends up becoming more
complicated than you thought it would be
and you need to customize you can always
do that later on
Nathaniel says with a video replay in 4h
deer still blurry actually the video
replay will still be in lower quality
which really stinks that's I that's why
I really don't like to have to do
streams from home I maybe could record
the video while I'm streaming it with
OBS and then upload it later that would
be a huge file size the off to think
about that and see cuz I'm pretty sure
you can do that with OBS so what would
happen I guess is that I would actually
just maybe take down the video for the
stream and then instead upload the video
that might work I'll think about doing
that next time assuming that I have
enough space on my hard drive the handle
of the huge file that ends up being made
from the stream I'll have to keep the
streams short maybe
okay
I didn't realize so mobbin had said
something about using Pied Piper for
something and I didn't get the reference
and Rahul says it's a it's a reference
from a TV show not in actual products
thanks for letting me know I would have
tried to look it up I I mean I probably
would have eventually figured out it was
from a show but thanks
they said it's from Silicon Valley TV
show so I've never seen that I want to
see it
I just haven't watched it yet okay cool
so Patrick followed up about using SAS
and it says it's it's in to anyways
about using it with create react app
cool awesome off to check that out thank
you
rich Rashad is there any way of using
the CSS grid system just like bootstrap
I don't I don't know how I can make and
react app responsive yeah you can use
any system you want like any CSS system
with react you know you just you just
plug the CSS and so it would work I'm
actually gonna try to have a responsive
grid with this site by using the newest
version of material UI so if you watch
maybe some of the episodes coming up
this week I'll probably try to get it
working this week and so it won't be
with bootstrap but it will be a grid
system
Patrick asked about the shortcut to skip
to the next instance of text from
multiple cursors I guess was it command
do2 to skip the next instance I don't
know the skip well I've never used the
command to skip but that would be really
useful but I've never taken the time to
learn it I've always figured there there
was one all right Jordan says hi hey
Jordan thanks for watching
Alfonzo says hi on my break at my coding
bootcamp cool well thanks for your uh
thanks for watching I hope everything's
going well at the coding bootcamp also
Alfonzo how did you get your name to
show up like that that's really cool so
I mean anyone watching the video can't
see this unless you're in the live chat
but Alfonso's name in the life everybody
else's name is all just the normal gray
in a normal font Alfonzo has like it wow
it says he's a moderator okay is that
why your moderator how did you get to be
a moderator anyway I was just amazed
that he has a different color name
now I can I get I get to the part in the
chat where where my kids were making all
that noise thanks thanks for being such
good sports about it everyone
thanks sir
Zanna says my kids sound too cute thanks
they're safe and maxius is so cute yeah
they're cute they're really cute that's
I think the kids like it's really good
that kids are so cute because it's like
if you have kids or been around kids
before you know sometimes they're just
crazy and they just do things that don't
make any sense but they're so cute you
don't stay super mad at them right like
otherwise it would be really hard to
take care of kids but it makes it so
much nicer that they're so cute like
when I have to wake up really early in
the morning with the baby
like she smiles at me and laughs and
it's like okay I feel like I'm gonna die
cuz I'm so tired but it's still fun
because I get to you know I get to see
her for a while before work so so that's
cool I think
I think it's it's definitely the
cuteness has its its purpose Nalla cool
sebastian says yes 9 year old twin
brothers cool Santa says you should
invite them over when you were at work
too if they've they've come into where I
worked before and it usually is like the
same thing it's me saying okay let's try
to be quiet people says hello everyone
hey people thanks for joining us
Blake says six brothers and sisters
awesome that's really cool
okay so Mauro says why not you switch
and router then don't use exact and
route well Wyatt I guess I could use
that the reason why it's simply being I
had no idea that switch existed so
thanks for bringing that up often check
it out now like I said I said a little
bit earlier I just literally just
learned how to use react router a couple
weeks ago and I haven't worked with it
very much just in my side project for my
course which I don't get to work on very
much so yeah so there's a lot of stuff
I'm sure about react router that I don't
even know is possible
so off to check that out thank you for
that
Sebastian says wow Chrome eating on my
rim yeah it does that occasionally does
ok Nathaniel says you don't need to use
flux on Mac so flux was the thing that
we were talking about that would
automatically make Demi your screen and
you know shift the light so that it
would it wouldn't keep you awake at
night as much so evidently Mac has night
shift built-in and so you can just
enable night shift so oh cool that's
good to know after do that
okay Zanna says and this is back to what
we're talking about with you know
sleeping and you know getting good
exercise and so that I can be able to
sleep and she says both me and my
boyfriend writing code we have a big
garden and we make sure we work out as
well that's cool yeah I think that is
probably important I usually never have
trouble sleeping if I get a good you
know workout in during the day although
sometimes if I work out at night it
wakes me up and I can't go to sleep so I
have to make sure I get it in earlier in
the day if I work out in the morning I
actually am really awake right after the
workouts it's kind of nice it's like
better than coffee
okay I see hamza mentioned night shift
as well for Mack Blake says PC versus
Mack for coding is both lately I've been
using a Mac a lot so I'm kind of partial
to a Mac for coding PC is always gonna
win I think when it comes to gaming but
with the Mac it could just be that my
Mac is just a better computer than my PC
in terms of how much RAM it has and
things but my Mac just seems so much
faster than my PC and my PC if the
desktop but has a decent amount of RAM a
nice video card like it should run well
but it just doesn't compete with with
the Mac it seems like I click something
on my Mac and it immediately happens on
the PC like I have to wait for
everything so maybe if I had a PC with
with enough RAM you know maybe it would
be better but I don't know I like I like
using the Mac now I don't like that they
cost so much money but I do like that
they function really well
well Sebastian said just saw an article
claiming that Firefox version 56 can
open about 1600 tabs in 15 seconds
that's amazing I mean why would you want
to do that but that is amazing well
Nathaniel says melatonin gave gave him a
ton of vivid nightmares that's it's
never happened to me when I've taken
melatonin that's crazy I didn't even
know you could have a reaction like
that's a melatonin Oh Blake says the
newest Windows 10 up say update has a
nightlight setting okay cool
Sagat says hi
hey thanks for joining us Nathaniel says
upload the video at work so if I were to
record the video here just upload it at
work least your network actually I might
have to do that I might hit my data cap
at home if I try to upload too many
things
maxime a says it's getting late in
france and leaving thanks for the stream
you're welcome thanks for watching
thanks for sticking around sort of you
know even though it was so late John
Hanson says thanks Jessie
set up something different where my
entry point is an array and the output
goes to a resolved directory file bundle
I did not have separate CSS and J's for
each page okay my react built into web
pack has no errors on build everything
compiles but for some reason the
JavaScript in react code is not running
not even a simple console.log John if
you I'd be happy to take a look and see
if you have it on github or something
just you know send me the link like it
on you know you can direct message me on
Twitter or something and I might not get
a chance to look at it right away but uh
you know try to look at it when I can
Jordan says there there are nine kids in
my family that's awesome
big families are really cool cuz I think
like you know you wouldn't get bored I
mean nine kids that's the whole baseball
team you could literally have a baseball
team that's just your family that's
really cool
James says agree on that Mac is better
but the PCs good for gaming yeah that's
sure that honestly all I use my PC for
anymore is gaming
I don't game that much but I just bought
my son my eight year old I bought in
minecraft for his birthday
so he's been using my PC that used to be
what I developed on and now he's been
using it for minecraft which they games
really cool I never played it before and
it's super addictive so I need to like
watch out so I don't play minecraft all
day and not get anything done
Nathaniel says benadryl is good for
sleeping take two of them you fall
asleep so fast yeah you definitely do
but if I take benadryl fall asleep I
feel so tired the next morning cool
patrick says command k command d skips
the next section I think cool I often
try that let's try right now
alright so let's say command K D cool
haha check that out look it skipped us
so I skip these two sections and then
skip down to skip this one kept going
that's awesome okay one says same one
works works and Ubuntu Ubuntu but then
uses Windows for gaming
Hamzah said in Pakistan they make fun of
people have a lot of kids and not a lot
of time yeah in the in the United States
actually it's it's weird like big
families sometimes get like a lot of
like negativity people I don't know why
people get freaked out by big families
I'm in a unique place where I live in
Steubenville Ohio in the United States
there's actually a lot of big families
like way more than in most parts of the
country so it's not really like I have a
family of four and a lot of places a
family of four is seen as a above
average sized family but around here
it's not seen as a big family at all
because you know but Mike my children's
friends from school they have six seven
eight there are some families that have
twelve kids so like six kids would be
more of an average-sized family around
here like eight is getting kind of big
and then above that is a big family so
it's kind of a weird a weird spot I'm
sure it's different at different
different parts of the world but yeah I
always said when people ask me how many
kids I wanted to have I would say I'd
like to have a football team but I'll
settle for a baseball team and they
always looked at me like I was crazy I
thought it was funny but they thought I
was nuts James says in Utah there are a
lot of big families as well cool
yeah like I said I like big families I
think that's that's cool all right I
think I'm gonna wrap it up the streams
going on oh yeah it's it's almost 4:00 I
definitely I have to wrap it up I have
to take my son so yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna wrap up the stream I got through
all of the the live chat so I think I
covered everybody's questions if not
just sent to me on Twitter put them in
the
comments in the video I'll be back
tomorrow I'm pretty sure that the
network will be stable tomorrow and I
can stream from work and I don't think I
have anything going on so it should be
the same time but I'll schedule the
stream as early as I can and I'll post
on Twitter as well to let you all know
ahead of time when I'll be streaming and
[Applause]
thank you so much for watching and for
helping me out in the live chat and I'll
see y'all tomorrow
you